is there a specific structure you use or
prefer when writing screenplays well it
depends on the script for example right
now I am writing a screenplay I've just
started writing screenplays based on
true true life stories this is my second
one I'm in right now and it's a whole
different experience than the other
stuff I did which is just original
material I prefer writing the true story
or the stuff based on real life stuff
because quite frankly the people's
stories are better than my imagination a
lot you know some some of their own
stories of what has happened is better
you know than what I would make up and
and in those cases you know I have to do
a lot of research and adapt so adapting
a script and an original screenplay are
two different things for an original
screenplay I usually start with the
characters and let them talk to each
other and kind of have and I have an
idea of the plot I don't outline I I
just let the characters infer the plot
like I know the concept or I know the
overall beginning middle and end and I
let the characters decide how we get
from the middle in the end I let them
you know just bounce off each other
again like improvising and then I build
around that but for adapting you can't
really do that so you kind of have to
gather all the facts and do all the
research and then it's honestly
something I'm learning to be to be to be
honest I I'm I'm really just kind of
writing out all the things the great
moments that I think in in this
particular script on writing and and
then I knowing that I'm going to cut
half of them out but just really I write
them out because they're fun they're
great they're interesting to me and then
when I find out they're not interesting
to anyone else when I do a little again
I'll give it to ten key people and I'll
see the consensus of what is working and
what is not where is the screenplay slow
which character is not needed can I take
you characters and combine them I'll do
that stuff after I kind of give it to my
inner circle of people who I think are
smart and Trust bouncing a screenplay is
very important off of people if you have
the ability to do that
you